countering malign Kremlin influence
that's how the US Agency for
International Development has called a
new strategy now to help European
countries avoid outside meddling and
reduce their dependence on Russian
energy when Moscow has quickly branded
that anti Russian propaganda are seeing
a correspondent more gas teams across it
US aid has unveiled a new plan strategy
officially aimed at boosting the
resilience of partner nations
unofficially it appears to mean giving
lots and lots of money to anyone that
vocally and demonstrably doesn't like
Russia politicians businessman media I
mean it's in the name by countering
malign Kremlin influence plan these
efforts will include creating tools for
reform-minded leaders in civil society
voices to tackle corrupt government
practices that Kremlin agents often
selectively exploit for Moscow strategic
benefit first off the u.s. apparently
wants to cut out Russia's voice I mean
the aims aren't exactly vague what could
they mean preventing Russia others from
meddling in elections okay preventing
Russia from lobbying for its interests
negotiating not okay it works both ways
I mean we know what some of the reform
minded leaders and civil society voices
in the US alike us aids funding will
build the capacity of indigenous media
to provide trusted independent news and
information sources should be fine and
all if America's own independent news
and media weren't viewed as biased by
its own people yeah trust in the media
is still abysmal
Americans believe it's biased it's even
worse for online media by the way
remember when Facebook hide a
fact-checker
linked to the US government Poynter
Institute for media studies to filter
out unreliable sources and they ended up
filtering out a
in political views before they were
caught that's my point why don't they
spend that cash on making America's own
media believable to reduce European
Eurasia's dependency on Russia USA's
assistance will include working with
individual states to create effective
pro-growth legal and regulatory
frameworks and assisting them to join
well-functioning local and regional
energy markets
ah there it is the crux of it hiding in
plain sight American shale / Russian gas
more expensive more cumbersome more
political yet it's full of freedom the
freedom gas they said that I have no
idea how they do it with a straight face
increasing export capacity from the
Freeport LNG project is critical to
spreading freedom gas throughout the
world by giving America's allies a
diverse and affordable source of clean
energy with the US and another year of
record-setting natural gas production
and pleased that the Department of
Energy is doing what it can to promote
an efficient regulatory system that
allows for molecules of us freedom to be
exported to the world it's a whole
package money to the media which cries
Russian wolf money to politicians who
get the American Way money to lobbyists
and get a nice little kickback from
selling American gas Moscow of course
isn't happy the term countering is a
clumsy attempt to conceal the aggressive
offensive approach this conception is
blatantly aimed at propagating
russophobia in the world especially in
neighboring countries - Russia on our
side we have proven multiple times that
we are open to establishing constructive
cooperation with the US on a basis of
equality of rights and the consideration
of mutual interests however malicious
anti Russian propaganda by Washington
which strives for global domination
cancels out these efforts it's a great
pity by the way saving best the last you
know why US aid was expelled from Russia
seven years ago why four in
election meddling Fiasco before that
became a big thing now isn't that ironic
unfortunately a mentality took took hold
of the establishment in Washington early
after the demise of the Soviet Union
that there could only be one global
superpower in the United the United
States had to have hegemony over the
entire world and not just Russia Russia
specifically but not just Russia China
Iran Venezuela any country that doesn't
come crawling to on hands and knees in
front of Washington and to kiss the ring
is regarded as a quote threat and since
Russia is the foremost military power
that is not under the control of the
United States that's why we've seen
things like the expansion of NATO and
something like this which is kind of a
an information analog to NATO expansion
which is to try to ensure domination of
Europe and to isolate Russia as much as
possible
you